what are your favorite roles that you've
played all time oh I think keeping the
faith you know playing on in that and
EDTV was super fun cuz Ron Howard
directed that and he's so amazing and
working with Matthew McConaughey and
Woody Harrelson every day what would you
like to work with Woody Harrelson I've
been I've interviewed him and it's that
is an experience and a joy by the way
very funny guy
one of the most relaxed human beings
I've ever met yeah for reasons that
confound me frankly and I don't know how
he does it but what was it like to play
scenes with him so much chamomile tea he
so he eats a raw diet which provided
some flatulent situations so I had to
it's just like this ever happens on
behind the actors studio well that was
compelling because we both went to a
great zone boys your fartiest code here
of all the co-stars which one was the
most gaseous yes woody harrelson yeah
the sweetest when he owned it up what do
you own so no so we would I got to make
out with Matthew McConaughey everyday
which I would rub in my husband's face
I'm like well I'm going to work I'm
gonna go make out with Matthew all day
right he'd be like have a great day
enjoy it while you can
and then so Ron would say okay the
cameras are rolling and action and right
when the cameras were rolling would he
would fart and oftentimes I'm making out
with Matthew so I'm like making out with
Matthew and what he would fart and I
were it we're doing the scene in his gas
and then we'd be like woody oh come on
you'd be like there's more room on the
outside then there is on the inside
got to write that down that's a good
you